someone recently asked the question how
do you make a watermark with blender
video editing
awesome question let me show you so
first we're going to open
blender here and we're going to go to
file
new video editing to get to our video
editing interface you may have a
template you load or something speaking
of that i'll show you that real quick
just in case you don't
so here in our video editing we want to
adjust a few settings right off the bat
we'll go down over here
and change our output to where we want
this to render in the end i guess videos
is fine actually i'm going to make a new
folder
call it renders or just render
i like to store it in a folder called
that way they're easy to find
change the file format to ffmpeg video
go down to the encoding click the drop
down
change the audio to aac that's my
standard and that generally gets things
rendering
well now i'm going to do file save as
i'm just going to call this video
[Music]
editing template there's another just
random hot tip for you
and so once you uh load up blender you
can go to file
open or open recent and just open this
right up all your settings are ready to
go
now when you save your next thing you
want to save as and give it a different
name
once you're you know doing some work
that way you keep this template
preserved
but it's easy enough to uh go back if
you need to all right so
let's let's make a watermark first of
all we need a video do i have any video
files maybe i have one from yesterday
videos there's this one yeah i did this
one yesterday there's the one that's
currently recording yeah i'm on a laptop
that only has one drive so
gonna have to deal with it you guys all
saw this video
if you didn't go watch it just my last
one right before this
and uh yeah i guess yeah you know i feel
obligated to say go watch it but
you know look at the topic side for
yourself all right so there we go i just
stretched this out to the end
i guess i was blabbing without telling
you what i'm doing which is going to be
not helpful for a new user so what i did
is i just clicked in here
anywhere and i hit page up page up goes
to the end of the frame
then i just change this end render point
right here
current frame to the end final frame of
the playback rendering range
so that way now uh it's going to default
to this um
you know you end up shortening this by
the end because you cut parts and stuff
so take that for what you will so
watermark watermark you ask all right
let's make a watermark what's required
in a watermark
well you typically want a small little
image that represents
your brand right let's open [ __ ] imp is
a free image editor
you might use photoshop if you already
know how to do the image part then you
can skip
all past this but just for this person
who's totally lost and doesn't know how
to do this at all
i will show you how to make the image
for your watermark
image as well rhetorical image
statements
all right so first you got to decide
what size you wanted so we're going to
go file
new and we're just going to do a small
one we'll do 512 by 512
nice little square watermark sure why
not so we get this background
that is not opaque but uh so what i
usually do
is i just create a new one with ctrl
shift n
create a new layer make sure the
transparency is well filled with
transparency perfect
and delete the old one you can also work
up the old one and
make it transparent but i just do this
because it's quick it's a few buttons
you hit okay
and now you want to just design your
watermark on here so you come over here
to these tools
and yeah i'm not going to teach you all
about [ __ ] i'm sure there are a zillion
tutorials on youtube about [ __ ] so i'm
just going to do something quick and
painless
just to get it in there i'm just going
to get some bold lettering here
uh and just type something say our
company is named uh
big ben's bread so we'll go like
big ben and then i'll have like a little
bread thing under here because because
why not
change the color of this i'm gonna make
it white give it
i'll do some more to that real quick but
first of all let's work up big
ben this is the most random thing i know
let's make a new layer for the toast
uh let's just draw a toast uh we'll do
it like this
make this a little smaller go like this
make a little bread thing all this
this is going to look like a hat i guess
that works
yeah all right deal
for example it doesn't need to be good
okay let's move this up here
let's just move this a little bit
actually i'm probably going to make
those
letters a little bigger let's go to text
again
i'll put bread down here just the color
of this
to the one i last used there we go
uh we'll make a little better bigger
down here because why not
you know i should just make one for my
channel obviously you know it's like the
obvious thing to do
but i like to break the meta meta
breaker over here
that's that's what's going on press t go
to text i want to make this a little
larger
it's an awful logo this is a terrible
logo i don't know let's just finish it
anyway
let's get some brown uh what's about
right there i guess
that's not where i wanted it okay let's
go to this layer click there
uh give a little lighter color for the
inner of the bread let's put some drop
shadow on these letters
let's turn up the opacity set this to
around
zero see how that looks all right but i
think it's getting clipped
so let's right click on this go to layer
to image size
and filters re show the drop shadow
let's go like that go like that okay
that's a bit
much change this to zero all right well
that's starting to be readable
now the the point of this text is you
want it to be readable no matter what
the background is it might be on any
color in the background that your video
is showing so if it's on white you won't
be able to
read this bread unless it has a drop
shadow
that's just a design thing repeat drop
shadow
but we have it on this new layer so that
gives the same one and we're starting to
look pretty good let's just put a drop
shadow on this brad as well
might as well repeat oh i'm on the wrong
one ctrl z go to this layer
repeat drop shadow there we go now we
have a logo
for ben's big bread has opacity
let's just export it file export and i
need to pick a place to save it
typically it's good practice to have a
place where you have all your stuff
for your current project but i'm just
going to leave it in documents for now
because whatever and i'm going to call
this big
ben's red i should put logo in the title
probably
okay fine i'll cancel and put logo
i typically like to put something like
that on my images if i'm going to use it
a lot or
big bins could have multiple things what
if i just make this company just out of
nowhere i'm doing guys
i'm going to make a company called big
ben's bread
and we're gonna sell blender toast okay
so now we just need to bring that in
here
um in my documents already just need to
refresh this you can also drag it from
your file explorer
but since this little section is already
ready to go and pretty much in the right
spot
we're just going to drag it in and now
you see it stretches across the whole
thing and looks awful you probably don't
want that so we're just going to zoom
way in and i'll show you some
some work up things first of all we want
this to be across the whole video right
so we're going to grab it press g we
just click the end to grab it you got to
click it so the end turns white you
click here you grab the whole thing
click the end you can only grab the end
so then i'm going to press g
to move or grab then i'm going to press
ctrl and it's going to snap
to the wrong side okay i want it to snap
to the other end so i'm gonna press home
while i'm hovering down here to get a
full view uh i can select an edge again
let's see
press g press well press home press g
okay now let's snap it to this end
so that's at the end this one's at the
beginning
so we have this bread logo it's going to
go across the entire thing
it's loading here as you can see though
that's not going to work for a watermark
so what do i need to do to work this up
a little bit
say you want it in the bottom right
bottom left wherever you want it doesn't
matter you'll see
here in a second so first thing you want
to do is you want to click on it and
then go over here to the strip
properties
and look for offset and check offset and
that will offset it rather than stretch
it across the whole screen
and now you can also go here to position
and move it around
and as you can see it's all coming
together but what if it's too big what
if that's not a good size one of those
just too massive of a watermark
what if you want it to be smaller what
if you want it to be like human size so
it looks like i'm eating it in this page
i don't know
whatever it is so i'm going to say let's
put it at the bottom left that sounds
good to me
and then it's still too big so make sure
you got it clicked on
go to add or you can press shift a if
you got the hotkeys down
shift a effect strip transform
this is the same one that's in add
effect strip transform
oh but now it's this presents another
problem we don't see the image behind it
that's because this transform has now
taken over
uh whatever this original one had and it
is now
applying transform properties but the
thing is it sets this
this uh initial composting to replace
so it replaces everything behind it we
want this to just be an overdraw so
we're going to switch this to overdrop
and back
to yeah we're back to where we were so
now also in these properties you can
adjust
the position again and the scale and the
rotation
so i usually leave the position alone
and
leave the position offsetting to here i
don't know if that's backwards and i
should leave this one alone and do it on
the transform
i'm not really sure but since you have
to check this offset anyway
that's why i start adjusting it here
because the properties
anyway you go to uniform scale and you
move this down and you make it smaller
and maybe that looks about good so i am
going to keep positioning it here
because this is
the position after the transform so
that's kind of how i do i get it
initially where i want it and then i
apply additional transforms i don't know
if that's the best thing to do i think
it works because
if you start framing this end with
keyframes and doing stuff with it
then it gets it gets a little tricky so
maybe we like it there maybe that's good
let's say
you want to do something really cool and
uh maybe
sure you want to shrink it down shrink
it down the wrong way
bring it over on the x bring it up on
the y uh oh scale of zero doesn't work
that's just totally
invisible let's just set these both to
28
okay 25 make sure you don't click off
strip otherwise you have to do
this again make this 1.25
or actually 50 let's just make it 50
now we want to adjust these a little bit
more manually drag this over until it
looks good
okay so about negative negative 22 this
one i'm guessing is going to be
different drag it down okay around
negative 20 let's say
so there's seems like a decent place so
one thing you can do that's kind of cool
because this is enough right here all
right you could you could render this
out you know i got a video with a
watermark on it
it's very bright a lot of times you want
your watermark to
be faded a little bit or maybe you want
it to animate so i'm going to give you a
little bonus and show you all that if
you want to keep watching
and giving me view time see this guy
this guy wants
your time so let's animate this you have
an offset here we can play
with but we can also play with just this
position
and scale so let's say we want it to
start out really large
and then we want to make it shrink down
over the first
or after eight seconds and turn it to
the watermark
we could do that so let's go to the a
second mark right about there close
enough
and this is where we want it to end up
let's go ahead and put a frame here
now let's go to the beginning i'm going
to press the home key
or not home key page down click on it
and now i'm going to put it where i want
it to start
so let's say well let's scale it
up to like 1.5 it's a little larger than
before
and we're going to find it here if this
goes off the screen it can become a
little hard to work with suddenly
but let's say we want it to go like this
start here
or i don't know i guess i like it
starting over here
and a little bit centered with my head
so now it's really
huge you can see something with the
shadowing that i actually kind of messed
up see how it cuts off the shadowing
right here and it has a sharp edge
you typically don't want that so that
the shadow
went off this edge a little bit so if i
were really doing logo design i wouldn't
let that happen
um but this is just yeah you know all
right so let's say we wanted to start
here it looks good so let's put a frame
here and we want to copy these settings
see 1.5
let's just call this 50 and call this
one
32 so 32 50 1.5 so let's go to about
second
seven we want to have a one second
animation time so from second
seven to eight actually let me just drag
this over so on blunder
if you go to the very corner here and it
turns into a cross
you can click and drag over new sections
so i'm dragging over a new little bar
down here
don't really want that so i'm going to
go like this
so we drag on the one to the left or
right of it and hold it'll
drag it off we want to do it right here
yeah here would be good
yeah so i'm going to drag this over
and it gives me a new one i'm going to
change this
window that i just made to a
dope sheet this will just allow us to
zoom in on our little timeline area here
and see
it visually it's really all it does you
can actually adjust with these two and
click on them
to access your keyframes so that's kind
of cool so it tells you what you're
doing based on what you've
keyframed in so anyway we want to go
down to about second
seven it's kind of hard to do let me
zoom in on this
okay right about there close enough
close enough so we're gonna put these
numbers back in here 32 50 1.5
keyframe those in and that's just so
this holds position
from the initial frame to 6.32
and then from 6 to where we set that
other keyframe
at about second 8 it's going to start
translating
so if you watch this from the beginning
it'll be big until like
right here and then it'll go through so
maybe starting on
frame six will also mark the
transparency
and start making it a little faded so
we'll go to that keyframe
so you can hit this little button here
jump to keyframe and
go back to edge right to one oh you got
to click on the strip thing first
there we go you gotta click on the the
bar you want to skip to the keyframe on
first
so i can jump between those by just
clicking this
a little lag time there so that way you
can mess with it
and i'm going to mess with a little bit
i'm going to click the opacity here
and frame that in right at the one
second and then we're gonna go to where
it ends so we're gonna make it start
fading a little bit we'll just make this
i don't know let's do a 0.5 but we do
have to make sure we save it so you can
press i that's what i'm doing to save
these i don't know if i've mentioned
that you can also just click this dot
over here
and as you can see it does a little
effect some of these do effects
for when you have changes i guess this
one does that's pretty cool
opacity is pretty good to know so that's
nice so you could
somewhere mark a keyframe and start
doing something with it again like at
the end
maybe we want let's just go to the end
we end at 9 41
maybe we want at the very end a little
fade time where it does a thing
so i'm gonna mark uh see it's gonna be a
little tricky you typically need two
marks when you want to change because
you need
well yeah you want the beginning and the
end basically
so i'm going to mark here everything
that's current
that way it stays locked in place for
the whole duration
and then we're going to go so we want it
to get maybe big and go into the center
of the screen
and then hold for a little bit so let's
just click here
so i guess we want the transition time
and then a final hold time
and we'll just make this something where
it's big and let's do 1.5 again
and put these in the opposite direction
put it right in the center
maybe that looks good so we'll just
press these buttons i'm going to adjust
the opacity as well
back up to 1 and there we go so during
that frame right there
during those frames we have a little
transition time
there it is scroll way over all right
and then we want it to hold to the end
and i guess you know these aren't going
to change this will hold to the end
but maybe we want it to fade out at the
end so we just right click on this
go to fade fade out now you could
manually do that with the opacity
and doing timelines but it has blender
has a nice little uh
shortcut there we can right click and
just fade things and we could
also fade in at the beginning fade fade
in
and now we'll have a watermark that
animates throughout our whole video
let me just get rid of this video this
video is not making it easier to edit
let me show you another trick maybe you
don't have any video footage
right and you just still want to make a
video promotional talk over it whatever
let me show you a cool little trick so
i'm going to open up chrome here
and let's go to just google images
and let's search for bread stores
and we're gonna for sake of example show
ones that are legal to use i think
someone can correct me on this if i'm
wrong but if you go to
well let's click on images first of all
so we get bread stores
let's go to tools usage rights i think
creative commons license are all
perfectly fine to use as much as you
want
and we could grab something like one of
these let's look for a high quality one
so we could also go to
size large and some of these look okay
i like the idea of having a store but
this bread one's kind of cool too
so we're just going to grab this and you
can see the size of the image i'm going
to right click
and just to save images it's called
cookies
something i'm gonna put it in my
documents okay now we can get out of
here
i'm gonna refresh my documents here that
i'm looking at in blender
and we're just gonna drag this in below
the whole logo thing and stretch it to
the end
zoom way out to do that uh make sure i
click the end first so i have that ready
you can't really click on it when you're
zoomed out and it's tiny
all right so there now we have the whole
thing instead of an actual video we just
have a logo
and it's spread it's bread man all right
i think i've given you enough tips in
this video
maybe a little bit too much but there is
in general how you can get a watermark
going and also
give you lots of bonus content so please
give this video a like let me know what
you think let me know if you want to see
more like this or what don't forget to
uh
say hello in the comments and i'll try
to say hello back
and stuff and you know also do
appreciate likes it does help get this
video propagated out and helps the
channel a lot
we'll see you guys in the next one matt
from code tech and tutorials over
and out oh one last thing
how do you actually render it how do you
get this okay you just go up here
and you click render animation and it
ends up wherever you set
this uh output as long as these settings
are correct it will render as
a video with your audio and everything
render animation
it starts it takes a while it does all
the
things oh this is going to be brutal on
my poor computer right now it tells you
what frame is on
depends how powerful your computer is
and how much you're doing
for how long this will take i'm
recording and rendering so it is epic
slow and i'm on
a little poor computer that i'm pushing
to the max right now
if you close it it stops don't forget to
do a save as
and change this from video in the
editing template to
big big ben's bread
promotional hire me big bin spread
please
so now in case this crashes or whatever
you can always just
open it back up geez i just can't stop
giving you guys tips i can't i can't i
can't help it
i like to give back it's taking forever
to open okay
yeah we go to file open recent and we're
back to where we were
ready to go i'll see you guys in the
next episode
thanks again
[Music]
[Music]
you